es ist einer dieser orte der typisch ist
für das ländliche michigan
wir sind in battle creek zwei
autostunden außerhalb von detroit
das durchschnittseinkommen ist um ein
viertel niedriger als im rest des
staates die mehrheit hat hier auch
diesmal für donald trump gestimmt sowie
ortrand michelle die ihre waffe immer
dabei hat
sie ist mitglied einer miliz der
michigan heimgartner durchläuft gerade
den aufnahmeprozess drinnen zeigt sie
mir hochzeitsbild make america grading
entstand auf ihrem kleid donald trump
hat das foto signiert
michelle und ortrand um die 30 bei der
arbeitslos beide wurden mütter als sie
18 waren beide bezeichnen sich als
patriot innen
das hat mir mein mann zur hochzeit
geschenkt melania hat er das gewehr
genannt sie hat noch mehr waffen im haus
warum frage ich die beiden brauchen sie
waffen
ich schütze mich selbst meine freunde
meine familie von leuten die uns schaden
zufügen wollen
es sind die antifa leute sie behaupten
antifaschisten zu sein aber sie
verhindern reden sie verhindern
kundgebungen sie verursachen gewalt das
ist faschismus
das zimmer ist vollgestopft mit trump
souvenirs und mit symbolen einer der
ältesten demokratien der welt dabei
erklären mir die beiden sei irland gar
keine demokratie
warum seid ihr keine demokratie er sei
demokratie heißt der mob regiert eine
konstitutionelle republik sagt hey wir
stimmen über sachen ab aber wir können
nicht über etwas abstimmen dass die
individuellen rechte fälle
es sind diese individuellen rechte auf
die sich das trump lager bezieht und die
sie einfordern so wie hier in lenzing
der hauptstadt von michigan
sie reden von wahlbetrug und fälschung
für sie ist und bleibt donald trump ihr
präsident
wir haben die einzigen die sagen dass
joe biden unser neuer präsident ist sind
die von der nachrichtenagentur ap es ist
nicht verifiziert und nein ich fahre
nicht
[Musik]
auch michelle ist an diesem tag in
lenzing sie hat sich ein
halbautomatisches gewehr um geschneit
wir versuchen den leuten die wahrheit zu
sagen dass unsere wahl gestohlen erst
vor unseren augen weil sie den
präsidenten so sehr hassen weil er so
viel gutes getan hat wir fahren nach
detroit amerikas autostadt 85 prozent
der bewohner sind schwarz lange zeit war
detroit ein synonym für armut und
abstieg aber gerade schaffen sie die
wende
die stadt ist jung und liberal joe biden
hat hier mehr als zwei drittel der
stimmen bekommen
der unterschied zum ländlichen michigan
könnte nicht größer sein
es ist ein bunter haufen der durch die
straßen zieht das ganze spektrum von
black lars metter fürs linken
bürgerrechtsgruppen
bei der abschlusskundgebung im zentrum
der stadt begegnen wir ray einer jungen
aktivisten
wir haben dafür gesorgt dass unsere
leute wählen gehen wir haben die wahl
sichergestellt und ab morgen werden wir
sie dafür in haftung nehmen joe biden
und kammerherr ist jeder andere der
gewählt wurde muss jetzt anfangen seine
versprechen einzulösen
detroit ist die heimatstadt von ray sie
hat eine organisation gegründet die sich
für ein gerechtes justizsystem einsetzt
ryan hat der tod von george floyd
politisiert beide hoffen sie jetzt
darauf dass die präsidentschaftswahl
etwas ändert in ihrem land ich fühle
mich wie viele andere junge leute sie
haben die finanzierung gestrichen bei
der bildung bei der krankenversicherung
in unseren nachbarschaften warum ist es
so hart eine gesellschaft zu schaffen in
der ein militarisierte polizei etat nur
einen kleinen teil von dem ausmacht was
eine gesellschaft wirklich braucht sie
machen sich sorgen wie es weitergeht in
ihrem land und ob alle am ende den
ausgang der wahl akzeptieren obwohl die
stimmen ausgezählt sind haben wir
aktuell ja noch keinen neuen präsidenten
es sind noch ein paar monate bevor das
amt übergeben wird es gibt noch
ausstehender gerichtsverfahren glaube
ich noch ist nicht alles in trockenen
tüchern
wir haben noch eine sehr gefährliche und
unberechenbare zeit fort es sind die
typischen schwarzen nachbarschaften von
detroit in denen ray aufgewachsen ist
hier ist sie mit ihrer organisation
aktiv ihr ansatz nur wer die probleme
kennt kann zur lösung beitragen
für ray und ihre mitstreiter wird der
kampf weitergehen strategietreffen im
park die korona zahlen sind hoch in
detroit kein privileg dass wir in diesem
land haben wurde uns jemals geschenkt
wir mussten immer um alles kämpfen und
wir kämpfen weiter mit klarheit und
einem plan wie wir dorthin kommen
es ist der alte traum von amerika von
freiheit und gleichheit für alle nur
dass sie ihnen michigan ganz
unterschiedlich träumen